- So a couple people did
respond to your headshot.
They asked if you
were mentally unstable
but at least they responded.
- Um, okay.
- Right and also I have to
say your social media game
sucks, Gary, big time.
You need to spice it up a
little bit so more people
will follow you,
it really helps.
- I mean my Instagram
game is pretty tight.
- Oh, interesting, does
tight mean awful now?
Because let's just see
what we have here right.
Food, food, food, a
bridge, a dead bird, food.
Yeah, really, this
is embarrassing.
Okay, that's an
embarrassing profile.
- I mean a dead bird.
What if I'm naked?
- That's not a good idea,
not with your body type.
(heavy bass, hip hop music)
(electronic game music)
- Ha ha ha ha, what's up
it's Gary from Gary gram.
I'm chillin at my crib
with my best friend
and my roommate, Rick.
He's playing video
games high on weed.
I'm about to get high too.
Like this video ladies,
so maybe come over?
I don't know.
- What the hell was that?
- Amy said my social
media game sucks.
My Instagram's wack, I mean,
which is totally ridiculous.
- I told you dude,
it fucking sucks.
A dead bird?
- Haha, yeah.
- Let me see your
phone, I can help.
- What are you doing?
- Hey what's up, it's
Rick, I'm here with Gary,
we're about to blow up his gram.
- What?
- And his face.
- What the fuck man!
- Now watch.
(electronic music)
- The video's got
over 2,000 views
and I have 300 new friends.
- Haha, yeah, told you,
I know my shit dog.
- Dude.
- Now you gotta keep
going, deliver good shit.
- Do I have to hurt
my body every time?
- Do you want to?
- No, of course not,
can't you help me
without hitting me in the face?
- On one condition.
- Okay, what?
- I get complete creative
control, no exceptions.
- Alright, I don't know if I
want to give up like every.
- Okay you food pic
posting little bitch!
- Okay, alright, alright, Jesus.
Alright, you can have
complete creative control.
- Smart, smart.
(smooth electronic music)
- Lookin good, kid, these
are some funny memes, Gary.
Although my favorite is still
the one where you get slapped.
Gary, this photo
has 10,000 likes.
Woah, you're in the game now.
Alright this is going
to make my job easier,
which is great, I gotta jump.
- Okay thank you
Amy, bye love you.
Dude, holy shit, thank you
so much, you killed it!
Did you hear how
fired up she was?
- All for the love
of the gram, player,
all for the love of the gram.
- Now it's time to celebrate
with a little Indonesia.
- Ah, I don't think weed
goes good with cereal.
Psych, oh!
- There's Rick.
(hip hop beat)
- Munchy town, going munchy
town, we hittin munchy town,
hitting munchy town.
- Munchy butt, munchy butt.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Hey, woah, woah,
woah, woah, woah.
That's a lot of jalapeno.
- Need that booty heat.
- Yeah that's too
much booty heat.
We're gonna need
more toilet paper,
why don't we do one barbecue.
- I said, complete
creative control.
- With chips?
- Yeah.
- Hey are you Gary?
At Gary gram?
- Yeah.
- I thought so, you fucking
stole @skinnygoys meme bro.
You fucking suck.
- Wait, what?
- You're a piece
of shit joke thief.
- No, not, I'm so
high right now.
What is he talking about?
- It's the
unforgivable sin, bro.
I got a buddy who
works at Instagram,
I'm gonna get you banned.
- For what the, what's
happening, what?
He's taking a picture, no!
- Hahaha, I have
278,000 followers bro.
You are fucked!
- You know, yeah, we
can get some barbecue.
- Okay now I really want
to hit you with a brick.
Stealing, are you insane?
- I know, I'm sorry, I
had no idea, I swear Amy,
I had no idea that those were
other people's photographs.
I had no idea.
- Well a lot of casting
directors won't even let me
submit you for background
work, Meryl Streep.
Delete it now.
- I will, I will, I will, I'm
sorry, I promise, I'm sorry.
Fuck, fuck, what
in the fuck man.
Why did you do that?
Those are other
people's photographs,
why didn't you tag them?
- Whatever man, those guys
are a bunch of nerds anyway.
There's real problems going
on, we're in a drought bro.
- Yeah, man, totally,
solve the world Rick.
Dude this is my profile,
I just moved to town
and now I'm a thief.
- Oh, shit.
- That's me @Garygram, this
is how you tag somebody
in a photo, you thief.
Everybody chainsaw
this guy's dick off.
Wow that's great, I've got
that to look forward to.
- This hate photo of you
has 356,000 likes, dude!
- I'm gonna fight this
guy, do people still fight?
Does that even happen?
(camera click)
What are you doing?
- I'm gonna name that
one thief for Sutherland.
The internet man, so cool.
(heavy bass music)